[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome Bethesda's senior global
vice president of marketing Pete Hines
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you guys you can't applaud too
much or somebody's gonna put out a video
saying I paid you to do that so please
keep your pause to it but thank you for
that genuine unpaid for applause and
welcome to the 24th annual quake on
now as everybody in this room is well
aware during doom turned 25 this year
and we're celebrating doom all during
quake on this year so what does that
mean well not only will Marty and Hugo
be up on stage here in just a little bit
showing you a lot more of doom eternal
but we've got a whole host of special
activities dedicated to doom from panels
to tournaments and a lot more to see
everything that's going on
visit QuakeCon org or tune into quake on
TV but don't worry this is still quake
on this is still the event that you know
and love North America's biggest land
party a place where people from all over
Texas and all around the world come
together every year to hang out with
their friends show off their custom rigs
play games and check out all the latest
games from its software and all of the
studios at Bethesda our special focus on
doom isn't the only thing that's new
this year we're also going global with
an inaugural two-day event in London
includes panels activities and hands on
gameplay quake on London helps bring the
quake on vibe to our friends across the
pond so they can get a feel of what
QuakeCon is all about so I would like
for you guys to help me give them a very
special welcome to quake on hey guys
we hope you guys are having as much fun
there as I know we are here now there is
one other thing that's different about
this year's quake on usually Tim Willits
kicks off the quake on keno but as many
as you know Tim announced that after 25
years here Tim is leaving it now he's
not just an amazing leader at in
software and one of the best creative
voices in gaming but he's also a great
friend of mine and I'm sure you're going
to miss him as much as I am tim has been
instrumental in the growth of QuakeCon
and he's attended every single one of
the 24 we've had so far before he leaves
to start his next adventure we wanted to
ask him up here one more time to say a
few words
so please welcome my very good friend
Tim Willits
[Applause]
thank you
Thank You beep thank you Thanks
thank you thank you thank you very much
that's makes me feel very good thank you
you know I also I want to thank everyone
at Eid software and everyone at Bethesda
for making in the last 24 years so
amazing and most importantly I want to
thank all of you our fans not just the
fans here at QuakeCon but the fans
around the year of sorry the fans around
the world that have supported us for so
many years
so but now before I go I still have some
things to do Pete and I will be
returning as judges for the dirtiest
keyboard contest yes so come down and
see us in the BYOC after Master pancake
and luckily for me I will still be
hosting the block party that's here
Saturday night so please come and join
me to celebrate this amazing weekend
thank you all now
before you go as much as I love making
games with you I think I enjoy I'm
having fun with you even more and so in
that spirit we've prepared a small
tribute for you before you go take a
look thanks to our friends at Avalanche
Studios
[Applause]
[Music]
around
[Music]
so now that we're alone now that it's
just us in the room do you guys want to
see something cool
[Applause]
[Music]
in the original doom we had a lot of
limitations when you are working with
the maps as technologies improved we've
had fewer and fewer limitations and now
we have the ability to create feeling
that we want
[Music]
thank you one more time for you Tim
Louis thank you thank you
good luck on your next adventure Tim and
we know we'll see you all around the
show now as many as you know Tim was
working on rage to a game that we've
continued to support since its
critically-acclaimed launched in May in
the past few months we've added all
kinds of insane updates and wacky
community events and our next big update
is out right now it's got a few new
totally free modes including new game+
and an ultra nightmare mode plus a lot
more check out what's in the update well
it's time to step it up your goons cuz
you're packin a real wallop goodbye Oh
Chris these badges
remember when anyway who died a thousand
times and beat the game or now you die
once you lose oh when did he grow wings
remember when your mates were like rage
do is you water streams catchy oh your
horses there's more cool [ __ ]
you insane cheeks doc look at him fly
holy guacamole
nice King you wanna know boys pop-ups
you got it oh yeah look she's a good
person but you don't have to listen to
this lady anymore and who doesn't like a
bj blaskowitz it's do or die soldier
[Music]
[Music]
so as always we've got a lot going on
this year at QuakeCon but before I share
some of the highlights I want to make
sure to thank the sponsors and
exhibitors who make QuakeCon possible
from tabletop games to tasty treats PC
hardware providers indie developers and
more we've got a lot of great stuff for
you to check out so be sure to stop by
their booths in the exhibit hall and it
wouldn't be quite con without some
competition this year we're kicking off
the quake Pro League with 20 of the
world's best players competing in a
year-long season that starts right here
at QuakeCon so whether you're here with
us in Dallas or watching the tournament
at home we've got a really fun new way
to participate just sign into the
FanDuel app pick the winners of each of
the matches and you've got a chance of
winning up to $1,000 and an Nvidia
graphics card you can catch all the
action and everything that we're
streaming on QuakeCon TV also going on
right now is the second annual master
Series for the elder scrolls legends
featuring the top eight qualifiers with
the prize pool of $50,000 the matches
are just starting so you can check it
out after this keynote is done all the
action is gonna be on the legends twitch
channel plus we've got a full schedule
of community tournaments in our BYOC
including quake world quake 2 quake live
and quake champions and because this is
the year of Doom
we're running competitive speedruns for
all of your favorite doom games
plus we've got the Elder Scrolls online
1v1 and nuclear nuclear winter for
fallout 76 and of course it wouldn't be
quite calm without a chance for some
good laughs and tonight's master pancake
theater is going to be exceptional
because they're going to be skewering
doom a movie that let's be honest does
it need a whole lot of skewering for all
the unintentional comedy but believe me
when I tell you what they're going to do
that movie is gotta be seen we're gonna
be streaming some big panels all
throughout QuakeCon as well including a
couple that are part of our doom con
programming now immediately following
this keynote we're gonna take a look
back at how Doom has influenced games
and the industry as a whole with an
all-star panel of Bethesda developers
and tomorrow at 11:00 a.m. we will go
and knee-deep in the doom where you can
join Marty and Hugo for a live gameplay
demo of doom eternal also on Saturday on
Saturday at 10 a.m. we've got a fallout
76 panel the team will be here to share
the latest on nuclear winter
wastelanders vault raves and a lot more
and Saturday at 2:00 join
Matt Farah and rich Lambert who are
going to be coming to walk you through
the Elder Scrolls online and all they've
got coming up and if you join us here or
if you join us on Twitch live twitch.tv
slash Bethesda you get a chance to get
exclusive drops during the ESL panel
along with the panels you can also try
out all the latest Bethesda games in our
booth here at QuakeCon including of
course doom eternal you can play the
Elder Scrolls blades on switch you can
try the latest updates for rage - you
can try the Elder Scrolls online and
fallout 76 and by the way for 76 we've
got a really cool component where we're
playing nuclear winter in the booth for
76 and as you play if you finish in the
top 10 as you play against everybody
else in the world
we'll make a donation to one up on
cancer for 76 dollars for every person
who finishes in the top ten
so every victory not only earns you some
bragging rights but you'll also be
helping support one of the half-dozen
charities that are here at QuakeCon
including one up on cancer anime here
for Humanity stack up gamers outreach
American Red Cross and of course Dallas
Pets Alive if you're here at QuakeCon
please visit these charities and giddyap
get involved many of our charity
partners are doing free giveaways if you
make a donation like the American Red
Cross which is once again sponsoring a
blood drive if you give blood you help
save a life and you'll get a raffle
ticket and that raffle ticket gives you
a chance to win this Wolfenstein young
blood PC from Coursera and in the spirit
of young blood being a co-op game if you
bring a fret a friend and both of you
donate blood each of you will get to
raffle tickets for a chance to win I
don't advise trying to do that more than
once because you're you need blood to be
able to play on the PC you win and of
course Dallas pets alive which is
featuring these awesome QuakeCon
exclusive t-shirts
there are there are two versions I'm
wearing the the dog variant and Jason is
here where's the cat Jason's got the cat
shirt on so we're selling these shirts
exclusively on Bethesda net for a
limited time as well so if you can't be
here and you want to get one or you are
here because we sell out of them really
quick and you want to be able to get one
go to Bethesda net for a chance to get
one there but working with charities and
doing some good is just one of the
quakecon traditions that you know and
love the other is big sales and special
offers and saving money and this year is
no different now if you're a place they
should now subscribe oh we've got some
fun news because fallout 4 Wolfenstein
new order and doom 2016 are all coming
to PlayStation now on August 6th
beyond that all of our games are on sale
right now and that even includes rage
too so you have a chance to get it at a
great price and check out the new
updates that you just saw in the video
and get a chance to play it while you
here at QuakeCon but that isn't the only
shooter that we have out now because as
of today both cyber pilot and
Wolfenstein Youngblood are released and
available to play now
and if you're in the mood for killing
some Nazis which is even more fun to do
with a friend
check out the launch trailer for
Wolfenstein Youngblood
[Music]
listen close girls the world is a dark
forest full of monsters monsters that'll
tear your flesh from bone to get
monsters little tear your mind and soul
I don't know it's her twice
but you're wolves and these are you are
woods all right Jess what's the plan
find our dad and kill Nazis
so you girls are sisters what is this
earth he gave me looking for something
and suddenly he was gone
[Music]
we're going to the hamburger bar mother
they think you will tremble before their
fury but you lack the strength
through your veins the blood of
blaskowitz
[Music]
what if it's too late then we keep
fighting together
wolfenstein cyber pilot and Wolfenstein
Youngblood are both playable and our
booth come by and start shooting
stabbing strangling Nazis and now quake
on it's the moment you've been waiting
for it's time for some doom eternal
let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you all so much just you makes it
haha be very sweet your legends I'll be
Keon oh you're a legend works for him
not so much for me I got to tell you
because of stuff like that the time we
get with all of you here at QuakeCon is
really a highlight of the year for our
team you guys are fantastic thank you
for being here for watching online and
for your continued support we have got a
ton to cover on doom eternal but first
you may have heard we are celebrating a
very special milestone this year the
25th anniversary of doom
that's right we kicked we kick things
off several months ago with the launch
of the Slayers Club this is an awesome
yeah I know we got some Slayers club
members in the house right very good it
is an awesome hub for everything doom at
Slayers Club calm you have to check it
out for all the latest news information
fun community events activities and a
lot of giveaways you can even see some
great in-game items in Doom eternal for
participating but we're here because
those original games were just so damn
fun right you know we've always said how
inspired we are by the original doom and
doom - and that inspiration continues
through our work on doom eternal so what
better way to celebrate the year of Doom
then bring doom doom 2 and doom 3 to
platforms that need more doom let's take
a look
[Applause]
[Applause]
yes Dhoom Dhoom 2 and Dhoom 3 on
PlayStation 4 Xbox one mobile and switch
yep absolutely and those are all
available today yeah we thought it was
about time our console friends had a
chance to rip and tear as well you're
welcome
in fact all of you here at QuakeCon you
get to play all of them on the Nintendo
switch this weekend over in the Bethesda
booth so you definitely want to check
that out absolutely you're gonna love it
but they aren't the only doom games
playable at QuakeCon this year yeah
that's right we brought you our demo of
doom eternal we were honored to win a
ton of III awards and nominations
including best action game so we knew we
had to bring it to quake on for you guys
I got to tell you though we packed a lot
into that demo it only scratches the
surface of what you'll see and do in
doom eternal from the first kill in the
game to the final boss fight you will go
on a journey unlike anything you've
experienced in a doom game before in
fact here's an exclusive look at one of
our favorite new doom demons in Doom
eternal check this out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
that guy he's called the doom hunter and
he's totally awesome and you're gonna
love fighting against him he's it's sick
it is sick definitely and we'll have
even more from the campaign leading up
to our launch on November 22nd but we
want to talk about the totally new
online experience for doom eternal
battle mode
absolutely you know from the very
beginning our vision has been to create
an engaging and competitive multiplayer
mode that has varied pacing tons of
drama and deep strategy and we had to
look no further than the single-player
campaign to find all the ingredients we
needed
battle mode is built from the same doom
combat DNA that you know and love where
skill and power of one fully loaded
Slayer takes on the teamwork of two
player controlled demons and I'll tell
you playing as a demon is a great change
of pace from playing as the Slayer each
playable demon is simple to understand
totally unique and allows for different
play styles and strategies we're going
to take a closer look at a few to start
welcome to doom eternals battle mode
this two versus one multiplayer gives
players the chance to experience the
fast growth of single-player with their
friends with five playable demons and
six unique Maps at launch battle mode is
a whole new way to play doom to start
let's take a closer look at its playable
characters
the revenant one of the most versatile
and agile demons his jetpack and - allow
you to move quickly through the
environment his shoulder-mounted rockets
deliver consistent firepower while his
special attack that targeted rocket
barrage delivers heavy long-range damage
the pain elemental his ability to fly
gives him a bird's-eye view making it
easier to track the Slayer and attack
from the air but that makes him more
vulnerable when he's not using his
rechargeable soul shield the man Cuba's
big beefy and badass
he's got heavy cannons flamethrowers and
tons of health all of which make him
lethal in a close quarters fight with
the Slayer while he's not the most
mobile demon his smoke bombs can obscure
his position or flush out an elusive
Slayer but Dean's strategy goes beyond
their individual abilities all the
demons in battle mode can swap hazards
that damage the Slayer as well as summon
different combinations of AI controlled
demons that behave in fight just like
you expect from the campaign
dropping hazards and summoning Dinah's
is controlled to a summoning wheel
allowing you to use these critical tools
quickly when under fire
in battle mode players take control of a
fully loaded Slayer with all his guns
mods and equipment just like in
single-player the Slayer must
aggressively manage not just the demons
in the arena but also their resources
glory kill demons to replenish health
chainsaw to gain ammo and torch demons
to add armor but be aware each demon
player has a slow charging ability to
block those resources for a short time
during the round a perfectly timed
resource block can put the Slayer on the
ropes
thank you
that's a great example of where the
depth of battle modes gameplay and meta
strategies start to go beyond character
fundamentals to create moments of
incredible pacing and drama
let's take a look starting with
something simple like player outlines
demons can always see the Slayer even
through walls but if the Slayer is able
to break line of sight this outline
vanishes
each arena has been designed to allow a
clever Slayer to use the environment to
become invisible and then flank the
demons this can change the pace of a
match from a head-to-head brawl to a
game of cat-and-mouse that leads to a
surprise attack and then back to a brawl
every arena is also designed with two
portals facing each other at opposite
ends that can only be used by the Slayer
as Slayers learn to use the portals to
flank the demons the tactic can be
countered by demon players who drop
hazards or AI demons on the other end
working together is critical for the
demons when alone a player demon doesn't
typically stand a chance against a
slayer with all his weapons and speed so
Slayers try to isolate a demon take it
out and move on to the next the demons
can counter by staying close and working
together
there are also important strategies for
the Slayer to master in the air the
Slayer is tough to hit and the arena's
have been designed with jump pads and
monkey bars that a slayer can use to
traverse from one portal to the other
without touching the ground all while
delivering damage to the demon flares of
course the Slayers need for ammo armor
and health bring him back to the ground
so when he lands - chainsaw an enemy for
more ammo demon players can launch a
coordinated attack
one of the most dramatic moments in
every round is when a demon dies
once the Slayer has eliminated one demon
a respawn timer begins and the Slayer
has 20 seconds to eliminate the other
demon to win the round if he fails the
dead demon player rejoins the fight with
half health this quickly turns an
all-out battle into a tense game of hide
and seek
rounds are won when either the Slayer is
killed or both player controlled demons
are killed but strategy extends between
rounds as well players choose upgrades
abilities and even super weapons and
later rounds in a best-of-five match if
either side can win just one round they
gain access to power items like player
demons being able to summon the baron of
hell
for Slayers gaining the BFG
[Applause]
it's so good we can't wait for you to
play it we're so excited about battle
mode we know you want a competitive
experience that's fun and full of drama
and we know you want it to look and feel
just like doom so with five playable
demons plus the fully jacked Slayer
competing across six totally unique Maps
there's going to be tons for every
player to master and I'll tell you this
is just the beginning for us after
launch
we'll be regularly releasing even more
playable demons and maps of course all
for free yeah you're really gonna you're
gonna like it it's a ton of fun to play
and honestly it takes an incredible team
of people it did to create all of the
stuff that we get to show you up here
we've got a lot of them in the audience
I'd love for them just to stand up real
quick wave a lot of them are wearing
battle mode t-shirts there we go
many of them will be working the doom
demo so if they're wearing a battle mode
t-shirt they're probably from it or work
with this at Bethesda so give them a
handshake and thank them though really
really appreciate it we really want to
thank all of you for joining us today we
hope you're as excited about doom
eternal in battle mode as we are we
really are and we can't wait for you to
play the play them both when they launch
on November 22nd yeah
but before we go before we go let's take
one last look at the game including two
more playable demons that I think you're
gonna love one of them is the arch file
and the other one is the Marauder have a
great quake on
[Applause]
[Music]
one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks again to Marty and Hugo and
everybody its software for everything
that you've seen we've got doom eternal
playable in the doom booth everyone here
and Dallas be sure to check it out it's
awesome as well as all the other stuff
we've got in the booth fall at 76 rage 2
both Wolfenstein Youngblood and Saira
piyo Elder Scrolls online and blades
force which plus all the Osiris stuff so
there's a ton of stuff to come check out
play while you're here for those of you
at home visit bethesda net for more info
and news on all the games that we've
heard about and been talking about tune
in to watch the doom panels along with
our panels for fallout 76 and Elder
Scrolls online and don't forget to join
the doom Slayers club where you can win
some cool prizes for doom plus it's
literally the only way that you can be
amongst the very first people in the
world to try out doom 2016 streaming at
home with our new Orion technology and
of course if you're here you'll be able
to play doom eternal at home on November
22nd if you're not here you can still
play it at home November 22nd for those
of you here with me there's a ton going
on at QuakeCon so I encourage you to
download the app it's got the full
schedule and details on everything that
we're doing but don't leave your seats
because in a few minutes we're gonna
bring out some chairs we're gonna get
right into our first doom panel looking
back at 25 years of doom and its
influence on video game thanks everybody
have a great quake on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello people so I am Jason levy senior
community manager for doom eternal and
I'm Matt Grandstaff I'm the community
director at Bethesda welcome to our
panel celebrating dooms influence over
the last 25 25 years of the industry
yeah it's a long time before we kick it
off and bring our awesome panel of crew
of really important people for our
industry and we can talk about the game
what we want to do is show you a quick
video so let's take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah all right let's get this thing
started let me introduce our panelists I
think they're coming Kevin cloud Hugo
Martin sure your your Gustafson top
Vaughn and Tom Mustaine yep come on out
guys welcome so many of you might know a
lot of these guys especially I got to
say your congratulations Youngblood just
came out today and then I propellant as
well so from applause to you if you guys
want to kind of go down the line and
tell us sort of what you do right now
what your role is and kind of the impact
the gym is you know had on you Kevin
cloud my role as a senior producer I did
software right now
dooms had a huge impact on me because I
started with the working on doom so
massive impact on my life and you know
excited to see it still around and
kicking so fantastic you go creative
director I did software and yeah it's
been
I mean it made us move to Texas so it
dramatically changed our life which is
often we love living here and and it's
great it's so fantastic to be a pop part
of pop culture history you know which is
cool I'm the executive producer at
machinegames
and I mean for me personally our quake
of course has been the the big
inspiration and something that has you
know yeah it's a big part of my career
but it's software titles in generals in
general have always been something that
we have you know looked at in draw
inspiration from over the years
so I'm senior vice president of
development for Bethesda Softworks
and
it's amazing just the relationship with
doom as a fan just playing the original
you know original episodes and then
having the opportunity to work with this
team and you know growing the brand from
from kind of where it where it was with
doom 3 and working with this team
specifically on doom 2016 it's
phenomenal yeah my Tom Mustaine I'm the
co studio director of Bethesda Dallas
and yeah doom doom awoke something
inside me the first time I turned the
corner and II 1 M 1 and saw stairs going
up I was like I need to make things for
this and that was the beginning of my my
journey to make levels for doom and from
that that's why I'm sitting here today I
made non stop doom things thank you
Kevin that basically open the doors
Kevin you've been working on doom since
the first game this this 25 year
milestone what does it mean to you I'm
old absolutely you know and just lucky
lucky to have been there and be a part
of it and and be a part of it for such a
long time and just proud to see so much
of the original doom you know alive and
well and doom eternal it's fantastic to
see Hugo you're working on doom eternal
obviously and help relaunch doom in 2016
what does do mean to you as somebody
that started not working on the team the
project I mean it's just awesome to see
that to be a part of a team you know and
and that whole process you know it takes
a great team of people to make a good
product and over the course of the six
years and really throughout the company
but you know the doom team has come
together and it's just been awesome it's
cool to see like guys like Kevin that
they they dig it you know and I mean it
because they were there for the
beginning so and and it's it's it's kind
of easy because the original doom game
is so good and that designs are so
iconic so we really just have to
continue to look at the source material
kind of
identify exactly what makes it great it
and and and we that generally never
scares us wrong but it's been amazing I
mean everybody's so happy to be here the
fans I mean I think that's been the most
enjoyable part of it all is getting to
meet all you guys and and read all your
comments even the even the bad ones and
because you're passionate about it you
know and and we're we're big nerds - so
we're passionate about doom as well so
the community and the team just been
fantastic any other reflections or ways
you the rest of you have looked at
working at Bethesda and it in the
ZeniMax family how you've kind of looked
at this milestone I mean for our system
it's of course been a very big thing in
general we have always been like I said
before
big its software fans and they have over
the years been a great inspiration even
from the very beginning when I saw that
stories and and we have you know been
working with this in a way where I think
we have looked at it software guys so
much we have drawn so much inspiration
from the games that we have in a way we
have completed with them as well and
what in what we have been doing and and
our ambitions to create good games and
and I remember when we started at
Starbase and - was the founder at
Starbase - Harry Dahl a great programmer
and they in in my mind he was the young
Carmichael of Sweden very very early and
this was the 95 at e3 and and - then
show the game called into the shadows
and that was at least me that was I
believe that was a title that could have
become the success that that quake later
became and and you know through the
years you know it it's been going on
like that and when I started working
with Magnus in 98 then he had your
status blinds to the engine and we did a
lot of work that it was amazing you know
we can do
school environments with it and then the
game we worked on got canceled and and
then quite freaking well came out with
all of these you know with their spline
isn't it looks absolutely stunning and
and then you know that went into then
the 2002 I think it was 2002 III when
they when they doing free demo came out
which which I specifically remember the
scene when this pink gear breaks through
the pipes it's a it was it was always
something that we do a lot of an
inspiration for me looked at a lot there
at that time - I just started working on
this next generation of stories onion
with with the dynamic lighting and the
per pixel stencil shattering and and
then when we released Riddick based on
that onion before doing free that was a
very big win for us and something that
has definitely big win for modernists
so when I say that the eight guys have
inspired us probably more than that they
have been basically made our entire
careers so of course it's a great honor
to be able to you know work with machine
when machines now and with Wolfenstein
on the same organization with the
support of its software so Kevin I mean
you were even at it before doom came out
and I'm just kind of curious like what
was that vibe around the office before
you guys actually you know sent the game
out into the wild were you guys kind of
aware of like wow we're actually making
something pretty magical or were you
kind of just like you didn't know you
didn't know how people are gonna react
to it I mean I think we had an idea that
we were working on something cool you
know you would never really know how
people are going to respond until you
get it out there you know at the time
when I first started it was almost like
a garage band right so it's just a
handful of guys we're working out of an
apartment and working on fold-out tables
and things like that so our expectations
you know we're relatively limited but
you know when you get to the point after
you release the game and
you you know start learning about we're
being banned in offices because we're
harming productivity we're bringing down
networks and college campuses you go
okay we've got something that's pretty
nice here so yeah then once it was
actually out in the I mean the reception
was insane people were just like you
know everyone was letting their friends
know about it and everything how did
that feel did you guys kind of feel like
brick rock stars in the sense like home
like we made this amazing thing you know
I can only speak for myself and how do
you yeah very lucky very lucky yeah I
mean it it was a pretty exciting moment
you know walk around you know grocery
store or something like that was the
nature Don and have somebody recognize
you that's I have to admit that's that's
pretty fun yeah but you know so much of
our time was just spent focus on work we
went straight from doom into doom 2 and
then started on to quake we carried on
crazy hours and our lives just almost
revolved around offices I spent more
time with Adrian then I actually did
with my family you know during those
years Adrian Carmack a fellow artist
that it software fantastic artists and
so you know that was we just sort of
rolled on to the next thing it's awesome
and I have to ask okay go ahead join the
company I basically did exactly what you
you just did with him we'd sit around
like ask him like a bunch of questions
than the cubes to give us some story
sometimes it's just like the coolest
thing it's like you worked on do you
have you have stories about you know
didn't a dentist office used to be next
to kind of where you guys were and like
people were drilling in teeth and oh
yeah yeah that's back in the so you know
we started off in an apartment yeah and
then we moved to this black cube
building if you guys are familiar with
this area over on 635 and 30 there's a
big black cube building and that's where
it office for a while and up on the
sixth floor was suite 666 which was our
office no matter over it and Adrian and
I had an office that shared a wall with
a dentist and it was very thin so we
could hear
when the dentist would drill on people's
teeth and so the drill was bad enough
but also of course you hear people
moaning and making their drill sounds
and things like that which was pretty
freaky only good fully work that
everybody was that inspiration for
hearing the demons on the other side of
the wall yeah it may have been it may
have been you know we tried to drown it
out with some Metallica
but the Dennis unlike that either so
eventually when they would moan we would
moan back what we thought was fair and
of course a lot of people may know miss
Donna's been at it for 25 years now as
well miss Donna is the it mom
what was it like the early days with her
you know being there basically she
describes this kind of taking care of
her kids in a lot of ways the way that
she was just making sure everyone had
everything they needed and it's still
the same way today I'm sure oh yeah if
you go visit it the first person you
meet is Miss Donna which is fantastic
because she is a fantastic person
she started with us back in the Dune
days so she's been a part of it in the
ax team for a long time and she was
originally brought on to just help us
out for a short period of time but she
decided to stay and take care of us and
that's what she's done not just taking
care of us around the office but taking
care of us in all parts of our lives
sometimes I mean a lot of the guys have
sort of grown up at it and she's played
a huge part of that so that's why we
love her
that's why she's our head mom there she
is
[Applause]
thank you you can't escape the limelight
I know she doesn't love the spotlight
but they're very nice to see her called
to do the interview for it and it's in
Texas you know this idea like what Texas
is like and that's the first voice I
heard it's like alright let's like Texas
I want you know a lot of stereotypes is
what you perceived a preconceived
notions of what its gonna be she's like
hey darlin how you doing I was a lot of
Texas right at the beginning every day
that's how you start your day every day
avalanche of Texas yeah yeah well I did
that's one last story about just the the
days it it'd there's a famous story
about an axe and a door can you tell us
about that yeah cuz I've seen some
pictures of it yeah yeah so it
that was a Romero he was he was stuck in
his office somehow the doorknob came off
or broke off and he couldn't find his
way out and none of us are really
mechanically inclined in carmack had a
battle-axe walk around I got from like
the Renaissance Festival or something
like that there's a giant battle ax and
he just yells stand back to Romero
Romero says what goes yells stand back
again and so
smashes through the door that's how you
do how you do it at it software Wow
right I got I was lucky enough to visit
those offices back in the day really
early on and it was after doom when
these guys were in the secret area
working on quake and that the way that
things worked there when these guys
would play deathmatch or it's just
everything amped up every screaming and
yelling and knocking things over and
going crazy so the battle ax heard that
I'm like yeah of course of course that's
what happened to be playing the Heather
that's how the door you know is after a
deathmatch or something but it was the
middle of the day right
lose it was not surprising after
visiting and seeing how people got amped
up playing the games so it's the year of
doom York but you actually got started
on a game other than doom quake can you
talk about how you got into the industry
I think there's maybe a story about a PC
or a parrot or something there I it
actually took me a very long time before
I got a computer I also couldn't afford
it and and I didn't save money either
you know I as soon as I got to my hand
on some money I spend it but my brother
he had a Commodores and the amigas and
sometimes he allow me into his room to
play game something on them but those
were rare occasions and then over the
years you know I played a lot of games
we paid the double dragon at the
hamburger bar you know we played
Nintendo games and and you can you came
at the local university where we can
connect the computers which was really
cool and of course fallout and doom at
my friend's house is but it was in 1996
and this is where the parrot comes in
where when I placed the bet on this
local hockey game and I won so and I won
a lot of money about four or five
hundred dollars and of course I
instantly want to spend them and the
first thing that popped up in my head
was to buy a parrot and then I called my
friend and because he had a car and he
could take me to you know whatever you
call this store that sell parrots and
but then he convinced me to buy a
computer instead so we went to this
electronics store and we bought they I
think it was a pencil 90 I would think
but we also bought then what would be
what would become one of the greatest
passions on my life and that's quick I
think we can all agree you made the
right decision
thank you you know ones get a parrot
later you don't need one you know just
go one excellent so Todd you know where
you were kind of in your life when doom
came out that your career was so for
part of my career I was with PC Gamer
magazine and I came on right after doom
had come out and it was right around the
time doom 2 was launching and kind of
seeing the the impact it's had you know
hindsight being 20/20 you can see all of
the things that happened but in the
moment what you were really seeing was
just so many people inspired by what
doom represented you know it was a shift
of a whole lot of trends in the industry
to just fast fluid technology driven you
know all of the sort of like hallmark
earmarks of what the doom represented
speed the sort of accessibility of
control just moving through the
environment so fast and there were a lot
of people who were just super inspired
by that throughout the industry and so
you had the phenomenon of the doom clone
that's just you know everybody's and
inspirati inspired by doom trying to you
know get that lightning in the bottle
and so for those years when I was with
with PC Gamer just kind of seeing the
sort of the reverberations the impact
that it had on everything that followed
it set a very high bar it set a very
ambitious goal of you know marrying the
action and the speed and the fluidity
and technology altogether and you know
then you had the moment of quake that's
kind of did the exact same thing but
added you know a whole new dimension to
it with Internet play you know q-test
and quake world growing it well beyond
that and then the accessibility of
modding and making that a theme of what
you can do with those style of products
it was just you know again looking back
on it it's it's obvious that was the
epicenter you know the release of doom
set the tone for what happened next
and it changed a lot of things about the
industry it made I think it gave life to
community around game
in a way that you didn't have before you
know the fact that they're still wads
being made today on doom the original
doom is phenomenal it's a testament to
you know what Kevin and the team created
is just amazing yeah it's incredible and
as you went on to you know join the
Bethesda family I mean you've been there
for quite some time so as it comes on
and we sort of finding yourself working
on you know doom and having it be part
of the family what did that feel like it
well it's pretty amazing I mean I I was
talking to laughy Taylor this was a few
years ago like pinching myself I have
Kevin clouds cellphone in my you know
his cell phone number and my phone that
you know I'm working with the people
that made that that impact and I think
when it joined the you know sort of the
Bethesda family that was sort of like
the tone across all the teams like wow
you know we're working with the guys who
did that and the the best part is
they're great like they're they're
humble they they're hard-working they
like to share they like to help and so
yeah so we've got you know we've got
this you know phenomenal relationship
with it and you know you kind of see
that with the relationship with some of
our other teams and other products where
they use the tact
you know they share some of the
sensibilities and the case of
machinegames enid they work very very
closely together you know kind of long
you know alternating between the the
products together and you know I think
it's all out of love and respect for you
know what the team has created yeah it's
incredible I know today we showed you
know the doom 1 2 & 3 are available on
platforms which they've never had never
been on before and intend to switch
being one of them I'll see ya I think
yep and that's in the DNA of the modern
game so Hugo I mean playing doom 1 & 2 &
3 you know like when you look at those
games I mean what is it about them that
really inspires you especially as you go
on to you know create newer doom titles
I it's kind of a little bit of
everything you know with doom 1 I think
when
when you make something that becomes
like a significant moment in the history
of pop culture like doom is it's like
it's the it's the logo it's the name
it's the story of how they came up with
the name from the color of money which
is also an awesome movie and just the
fact that that's an awesome scene and
the the design of the characters their
names like the tech the gameplay like
it's just all these things coming
together and we see that happen
sometimes in the entertainment industry
in pop culture something like I would I
would liken it to like Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles you know or Star Wars the
first Star Wars where it just kind of
all gels together
the it's a lot of pressure because you
know it's it's that good so doing 2016
and doom eternal has to be you know it
we don't want to embarrass the doom name
but that's that's probably the thing
that I that I find most fascinating
about it is to just analyze it from a
design perspective you know really what
makes it tick I think it taps into
something that we all have in us even
the name the the you know the did it
there's like this primal urge to just
unleash you know aggression onto the
worlds and and it games kind of give you
an avenue to do that in a politically
correct way I guess the and and that's
never gonna change you know like people
always want to just be doom guy and and
and and that kind of a power fantasy is
something that's in all of us so I think
it connects with people on multiple
fronts which is which is really hard to
do you know I was asking Kevin earlier
how much time they spent iterating on
the design of the characters because you
know in in art school you would study
characters like the pinky and like oh
the silhouette and the color and that's
why it identifies with the player and
you know red is like the blah blah and
and your answer was yeah which is
typically the case i mean i know kevin
eastman worked with him at blur and
teenager ninja turtles was just
something that he thought was cool and
funny you know like
we met Adrian Carmack at a bar recently
about a year ago all the team was there
and we were having a good time and he
was having a good time too and we ran
into each other like this is Adrian
karmic and it was really cool because he
was kind of schooling us on like hey
listen if you really want to make it
feel like doing you got to not take
yourself too seriously we're all like
that's what we say all the time and he's
like you know evil dead that was a big
inspiration for us like you know I mean
we're not we've been studying the things
that they were interested in from the
beginning but it's just those little
elements that have to be in place I
think to make something that special
that resonates with people yeah it's
working pretty well so Jason mentioned
yeah so Jason mentioned we did announce
the legacy titles coming to phone and
consoles today so before we talk about
those games a little bit more we have a
clip to show
alright ok here comes the desert island
question doom 1 doom 2 doom 3 you only
get to have one and why forever forever
it would have to be doom 1 from me I
mean it's the classic and its original
so yeah I got a lot of fond memories
about it so they had them one for sure
okay you get totally doom 1 no question
York it would probably be doom free for
me actually just because it's very close
to my heart in many ways so I think
that's why okay I'm a doom one guy okay
alright I
I need my double-barrel shotgun real bad
let's scoop two for me awesome awesome
so Kevin I mean you work on these games
like what is it like to see them
rereleased obviously there's people that
maybe never played them it's hard to
believe that that's possible but you're
out there I know so you know you're
taking your Nintendo switch today and
you're downloading them for the first
time what's that like a new audience you
know 25 years later that's super cool
and you know the thing is is that
surprisingly for me like playing doom 1
and 2 on the switch it just feels like
it's meant to play on the switch it's
super fun so for anybody who you know
hasn't played any of the you know the
old titles it's it's a great it's a it's
a great time to pick them up and play it
yeah it's cool yeah and if you're here
obviously downstairs you can you can
check it out which is cool so yeah but
otherwise you just download it I mean
it's there yeah why wait
I know when I think of the original doom
games the first thought that comes to my
mind is e 1 M 1 just going up those
stairs this fully-realized 3d world I
was kind of curious when you think of of
the classic games what what what goes to
your head first when you think about
them maybe from a work perspective it
might be different you know think about
the classic games yeah well sort of what
goes through my head yeah
you know again from a work perspective
it I want to go back and play doom and
doom - it just brings back you know some
memories of what it was like when I was
working on it
I remember the first time that I had a
we had just put the fire ball on to the
IMP
you know the empire ball isn't that fast
but it sure seemed fast to me the first
time I had it coming at me so we're
sitting there playing it and the
fireball comes at me and I basically
dodge in my chair right as if the
fireball is like coming at me in real
life and it just dawned on me how
powerful first-person shooters are
because I mean it's there's a thing
going on in the game that's eliciting a
reaction from me in the real world as if
it's happening I don't have to have VR
goggles on or anything like that to feel
immersed in a game and it's just a super
powerful moment that you know I think
that's kind of the core of what a
first-person shooter can deliver you go
any thoughts how good it was the first
my first real doom that I fell in love
with was doom 64 yeah I wait so I went
to art school and and I was a Mac user
so we were weird we were super
everywhere he went all the labs had max
with my friends and the dorms had pcs
and so you got to play Doom and and it
was awesome but as soon as they came out
on on a console that was when I was able
to you know play it play and I love that
one but it's it's a trip because like we
again we look at those games so much
when we make for a doom 2016 and doom
eternal I look at the resource
management of those original games you
know like yeah the plasma was awesome
and it tore up the Cacodemons but if you
overused it you'd run out of it so it
was like a thinking man's game you had
to like okay I'm gonna like save this
because this Cacodemons out here and
this door opens and there's all these
guys and we really strive to that that's
the genesis for the resource management
and doom eternal which was just like
make every gun count the the rocket
launcher in the original doom I remember
like it being awesome and hurting me you
know like if I didn't use it correctly
being super pissed when I missed a shot
because I was like and being super
excited when I walked into a room and
there was like six missiles on the mean
I was like oh this is good so we really
tried to create that recreate that in or
let that inspire us our design decisions
and doom eternal you know and that's
something they did in 1993 then you know
in the nineties in it it's it's just as
good today as it was then because I
think any time you make the player think
about their choices that means they're
engaged so it was overall what I
remember is a very engaging experience
and we hope that people feel just as
engaged in doom eternal okay Todd I know
you mentioned people should play it if
they haven't played them yet what what
what makes doom one two and three a good
primer for Doom eternal it's just the
sensibilities of it it's it's
unadulterated adrenaline and it's yeah
you know just pumping it straight into
your veins and going for it but at the
same time like Doom one you know and
sort of like they will the standard at
its set whether it was they were aware
that they were doing it at the time it
was just a happy accident is you don't
really have to know anything coming into
it but you know exactly what it is as
you're doing it and it's just that
purity of design and what it what it
represents like first room
don't die keep moving yeah it's a very
simple equation and so I think that that
translates throughout all the games
frankly and that you know it's a lot of
that simplicity of design that informs
you know the deeper aspects of the game
what doom 2016 you know started in sort
of the reinterpretation of all that
magic was you know making it that
tactical puzzle of the right weapon the
right you know right decision right
moment in time you know moving through
the environment choosing how you're
gonna get health choosing when to get
the health packs choosing when to go
after that glory kill and I think you
know that all of that just sets the
table for what eternal offers which is
even you know Depot perversion to that
yeah so for cokes I mean it's a true
generational title now 25 years right so
I love the fact that it's coming out
again on these on the new consoles you
know we've got folks that are growing up
right now
playing Minecraft and other pixel art
games a pic lark pixel arts kind of
having a resurgence
here's doom baby it's like the pixel art
dream right and doom has a purity to it
everyone gameplay perspective that
similar to Todd mentioned there's that
there's a purity about how simplistic
these combinations become and from a
design perspective we'd make levels
nothing's more fun than oh there's a
rocket launcher in the middle of room
cool and we gonna run over the rocket
launcher and and you know sadistic
designers like myself make a bunch of
lost souls come into your face you're
like I'm switching the rocket launcher
you got things that are gonna kill you
immediately so you know it's fun to try
and figure out those action puzzles and
that purity is there it's played its way
and influenced everything from a design
perspective for years and years and in
2016 and an eternal and you've got that
same you know you kind of have to figure
out very quickly in split-second I'm
gonna have to handle this scene this way
and pull this gun out and do this thing
and that's still there in the classics
but it's you know you've got the music
and you've got the resource management
it's definitely give it a shot if you
haven't yet it is it is the grandfather
of the shooter so the purity is there
that's awesome
yeah I know a lot of times people think
about doing one and two and they think
about classic doom but doom 3 really did
kind of take the series in a new
direction Kevin what was it like to see
you know going from these sprites to
like you know fully realized demons and
kind of a darker tone to see that game
kind of come on board well I love doom 3
actually I love the darker tone - I mean
it was a good time for us we just come
off of quake 3 arena which was just more
like an arcade action just all-out
shooter and doom 3 was a good
opportunity for the team to sort of
explore something with more of a
narrative a little bit more depth in in
the gameplay and in realistic
environments so it's fun to work on you
know that was I think is the first game
to have real-time dynamic lighting in
shadows which was pretty impressive for
the time
and normal maps and all of that so part
of the reason why we went for more of a
survival horror pace was to take
advantage or take advantage of that
lighting system really show it off the
other thing is of course the only way a
service could be lit is to toss a light
on it and lights were pretty darn
expensive in doom 3 so we really had to
be careful about how we used them so
that combination is sort of what moved
us into a direction of having more of
this kind of slower paced horror feel
for the game but it's super fun to work
on and and you know a fun game to play
through so yeah can't wait to play
through it again it's gonna be awesome
Hugo you know like looking back at doom
2016 one of the favorite moments for a
lot of people is probably finding those
Easter eggs from classic levels and then
eternal of course a lot of people are
noticing like the diamond designs are
kind of going back to that doom to look
even the plasma has a redesign so how
often do you find yourself just looking
at the original games when you're you
know in development for finally I'm
playing through quake 2 single-player
campaign and right now again you know we
played quick one when we started we
played doom 64 and we started the
project pretty much every time we
started doing game everybody has to
spend time playing doom you know the
originals and every time you go back to
it you find something else like the
resource management you know evaluating
doom 2016 and saying this game is great
and how can we make it better we could
probably make players think a bit more
about the choices they make with the
weapons they have like you do in the
original doom so I think it's important
to tap into it because it's good like I
wouldn't you know what we wouldn't use
it if it didn't work you know so some of
the doom 3 stuff is awesome because it
is a different style of game and I love
that game I played the hell out of that
one that came out but the the slower
pace of that game doesn't really
obviously work so you're looking for to
try to capture some of the as he said
the simplicity of the original game in a
modern triple-a shooter I think they're
just really good again I just can't say
it enough I mean it's
from a design nerd perspective like the
simplicity of the silhouettes and how
each silhouette stands out to the player
even in tiny little pixel form you could
read from across the room that's a mang
Kubis and the guy who hits the pose like
this this is you know the the arch file
and those guys are really scary and then
that sound that that guy makes that
means that there's a this type of demon
around the corner you're it's
communicating information to the player
really really effectively so and so
you're able to make decisions like
really fast and that's that's kind of a
deep sort of meta of doom that we're
trying to capture you know with our
games and so we look to it because it's
good and and and we want it to feel like
doom we continually want it to I'm a big
pop-culture nerd and I you know I'm not
too thrilled with the latest Star Wars
films to be honest and and yeah because
it felt reversal with it there it's not
Luke it's not that they are not looking
at the source material in my opinion and
enough to like like who is this guy like
Yoda would not say that like and and the
way they act and how flippant they are
with the Jedi you know like it's like
dude it's all about the Jedi you know
like and and so I we do not want to be
responsible for messing up someone's
childhood I mean these guys are like
telling you their life's work is
inspired by this game we're not trying
to [ __ ] that up you know
all right we'll have to talk star wars
afterwards you're working on Wolfenstein
games talking about Hugo looking at the
past games how do you look at doom games
past and even present up through doom
eternal when making the Wolfenstein
games you guys make we look at them of
course and we look we look a lot of them
you know to get a lot of that aid
feeling into them and all that retro
feeling into them and you know like it's
hard to say actually because we in a way
we both do this you know fast-paced you
know with a dangerous feel to them
shooters right and we are but they are
still very very different from each
other but they also have this retro
feeling I like that that's you know
that's one of the key things that we get
from the games when looking at the old
it's of the titles and all doom games
Tom you worked on Jim 2016 before
leading bgs Dallas what was that like
and can you talk a little bit about what
it was like starting with doom as a fan
as well
oh man has two questions but yeah so I
got the honor and that the opportunity
to work on doom 2016 and it was a little
bit of peeking behind the curtain
because I had no idea what to expect
these guys were so secretive and we're
just down in Dallas doing our thing and
it's over in Mesquite or up in
Richardson doing their thing and so
Kevin I talked to Kevin and he came sat
me down and doom 2016 he's like like
well what do you tell me about the story
when he's like that just play it just
play it I'm like okay and I played it
and my god it feels feels it's fast it
feels good I got glory kills it like
this oh my god this works I'm all he's
like okay we got to go talk for a minute
like just give me a minute
I'm gonna keep playing but that was it
was it was an astonishing moments I got
the peek in and see the team and Hugo
Marty the whole team there everyone was
so focused on making this game 2016 what
it was and that was a huge huge huge
part of why we got excited about being
able to be taking taking part of it so
probably the second question we will run
out of time so okay yeah we are running
out of questions left
Kevin let's talk about how
shareware was to the to the launch of
doom yeah me shareware was incredibly
important you know we were a small team
independent self-funded run about the
time we released do me shareware had
already existed for over a decade so it
was a pretty well developed market now
of course shareware was traditionally
more of a sort of hardcore a group of
buyers which was great for us because we
love communicating directly with with
that community a lot of people that were
developing shareware at the time we're
doing things like crippled we're and
stuff like that that wasn't as
successful we followed a model that
Apogee had pioneered which was this
three episode
give the first episode away and then
sell the other two which was you know
proved to be super successful but the
other thing that was happening in the
market were third-party companies were
taking the shareware portion the free
portion and putting it on discs and then
selling it you know in racks in grocery
stores of all places and gas stations so
this gave us a reach that that we would
have never had it was just really great
timing for us I think even if we would
have went you know just straight retail
with it through a traditional publishing
method you know we it might have might
have had more profit who knows but from
a perspective of getting out to a
massive number of people I don't think
we would have ever done that and
honestly I don't know if if doom would
have had the same impact as it did as
quickly as it did without it I have a
quick sprint for here real fast my first
version share that I got I got a PC I
had an Amiga and I moved over to PC
after seeing doom I didn't have doom yet
but I went into Circuit City and it was
running shareware doom so I bought some
disks and then whatever the computer it
was running share doom and like that
there and it was like a mission
impossible
and I copied all the shareware over and
brought it back and played it so yeah
shareware made it entirely possible as
we wrap up are there any final thoughts
that you guys have about just 25 years
of doom obviously you know what it means
to you and you know just to be here in
celebrating this and you know if not I
mean 25 years from now we can come back
and do this again but any thoughts I
better take my opportunity now to wait
for 25 years and you know just to say
it's fantastic again to be a part of it
software all these years but also just
fantastic to be a part of QuakeCon and
these great fans that's just absolutely
amazing I love coming you guys are
fantastic
I really appreciate it we can't mess it
up we just got to keep it going
it's good pressures good you know and
it's an honor it really is as I said it
it's it's fascinating to analyze what
makes it work and you should truly see
how smart it was and how amazing the
work that these guys did and how it
continues to help us make great games
today and and the fans and the community
that that I've grown to to love here in
QuakeCon and in Texas in general I think
you could only make a game like doom in
Texas and I think that yeah I I think
that I think that is awesome I really
often comes in yeah it's it I think
that's fantastic I think I would like to
take the opportunity to yes to say thank
you to my biggest hero of all the edge
software guys Tim Willits who
it's probably the single person that
I've you know inspired me the most
throughout the years and of course now
he's leaving it software for so many
years so I always wanted to say thank
you to him awesome huh
so you know for this 25 years of doom I
think you know there's the thing that
just sort of resonates with me is that
you know doom you can have your
favorites but there's not a bad one in
the bunch
and having played eternal I got I got
the inside track that I know internal is
gonna be awesome
probably my personal favorite so that's
just the exciting thing I know this
brand is gonna continue it's gonna be
something that as long as we hold true
to these ideals over the originals we're
gonna we're gonna be on the right track
yet I just thank everybody for playing
and thank it guys for making a career
for a lot of us here because without it
we wouldn't have liked I thought games
were magic things that came out of Japan
like that's how they showed up right
like oh I didn't know I could make games
and I started learning to make levels
and humans like it's possible and
without that you know there's there's a
whole industry that wouldn't have
existed if you guys hadn't suffered
through the pain of moaning and
screaming Dennis tear people and and hit
so many thing it is fascinating how many
things you guys did right from mods to
the perfect balance of this it's you
know four and B in 25 years like this
generational and I love seeing people
are still making maps today you can go
and check out do maps that are
mind-blowing today that we just couldn't
even imagine back then because there's a
community that's still just building
these classic new maps it's fascinating
so yeah thanks to everybody here their
plays and again to you guys for making
it possible for us to be sitting here so
that's right
well that's our that's our panel thanks
everybody for joining us if you're here
at QuakeCon be sure to go down to the
exhibit hall
check out doom eternal play the classic
doom games and have a great quake on
thank you thank you guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]